dix lettres de sang accusent omar raddad
du meurtre de ghislaine marchal
omar m'a tuer tuer avec un air donc avec
une faute d'orthographe
c'est ce que l'héritière des accessoires
auto marche alors été créé avant de
mourir le 23 juin 91 dans sa villa de
calmer ses dix lettres constitue-t-elle
une preuve suffisante c'est tout le
mystère que les magistrats et les jurés
de la cour d'assises des alpes maritimes
devront résoudre compte rendu de
dominique verdeilhan gilles dobler
souriant et impatients souriant détendu
décontracté quand ils arrivent au palais
de justice de nice ce matin un patient
lorsqu'il a temps de faire son entrée
dans le box un patient aussi de
démontrer à la famille de la victime que
la signature
omar m'a tuer n'est pas une preuve omar
raddad navré enfin de ne pas pouvoir
clamer son innocence en français je me
doute dit-il que cela risque de me
desservir
c'est donc par la voix d'un interprète
que la cour d'assises appréhende la
défense de sept accusés qui ne sait ni
lire ni écrire
sa présence à mougins le 23 juin 91
exceptionnellement j'ai voulu y aller le
dimanche si j'avais su je n'aurais pas
travailler ce jour-là son besoin
d'argent mobile présumé du crime
oui monsieur le président jallet de
temps en temps au casino mais ce n'est
pas le jeu qui m'entrainait à demander
de l'argent
en revanche je nie farouchement avoir eu
des relations avec des prostituées omar
toujours souriant quand il aperçoit au
fond de la salle son père qui évoquera
un fils calme affectueux non violent
puis viendra la barre son épouse en
quelques mots elle évoquera une vie
heureuse sans histoire avec leurs deux
enfants
une première audience à l'image de
l'instruction une première audience
durant laquelle la justice a tenté de
chercher une faille dans la personnalité
de l'accusé comme si le jeu les femmes
et l'appât du gain pouvait être la clé
de l'énigme sentiment de malaise car
deux ans et demi après les faits la
justice cherche encore un mobile et des
preuves irréfutables
c'est là l'un des points faibles de
cette affaire sans une inscription en
lettres de sang
l'enquète serait peut être resté au
point mort